croco contento secrétaire départemental
du syndicat unité sgp police à paris
rocco contento bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
gérald darmanin annoncé hier
l'augmentation à des contrôles de police
comment est ce que les syndicats ont
perçu justement cette annonce du
ministre de l'intérieur
écoutez vous savez le syndicat ou de
ladoux de tous les policiers et les
collègues de ce pays sont un peu
désabusé puisque ça fait plus d'un an
que nous sommes mises à contribution
pour veiller au début au beau contrôle
du premier confinement nous avons
ensuite accompagné le déconfinement
ensuite le respect du couvre-feu
voilà les connais aussi qu'ils sont des
citoyens à part entière en europe un peu
marre parce que ça ne correspond pas à
leur coeur de métier
je rappelle que le coeur du métier de la
police nationale c'est lutter contre la
petite moyenne et grande délinquance
en plus de cela ne m'ont pas de
consignes très claires alors c'est sûr
que dans les gares pour les personnes
qui vont voyager qu'ils vont changer de
département ou de région
il faudra une attestation dérogatoires
avec des motifs impérieux
mais au-delà de ça par exemple la mesure
du ministre qui veut que nous verbalise
ion au sein d'un département sensible à
rassemblement de plus de six personnes
ça c'est totalement un faisable pour
nous parce que nous avons des effectifs
contre 1 et puis des consignes très
claires à ce niveau là aussi donc voilà
nous ce que nous faisons dans un premier
temps c'est veiller à ce que les gens
portent bien le masque et respectent les
bonnes distanciation lorsqu'ils sont sur
la voie publique
voilà là justement on a appris la
verbalisation des rassemblements de plus
de 6 personnes concrètement sur le
terrain comment est ce que vous allez
intervenir comment est ce que vous allez
mais surveillée écoutez vous savez les
collègues feront tout simplement pas
alors il ya une différence entre
verbaliser si personne sur vingt public
imaginons une famille en train de
pique-niquer dans un parc avec quatre
enfants on va pas verbaliser les six
personnes voilà il ya aussi avoir un bon
discernement une bonne pédagogie ce
qu'on dira on fera respecter par contre
le
la bonne distanciation et les gestes
barrière des personnes voilà six
personnes sur le public c'est pas
dangereux c'est pas comme un
rassemblement de 200 personnes dans un
lieu clos de vue des deux parties
là effectivement la police intervient
interpellé mais des verbalisations après
au delà de ça les choses sont imposables
à lors des manifestations sur les
violences policières est ce que vous
craignez que l'image de la police puisse
pas tiers à nouveau justement de ce
renforcement des contrôles écouter un
petit peu oui
actuellement se déroule le fameux
beauvau de la sécurité que nous avons
d'où il était gp police provoquer avec
le président de la république est un des
thèmes du bobo de la sécurité si le
renforcement des liens entre la police
et la population
donc tous ces contrôles que nous sommes
entre guillemets encouragés à faire ne
seront pas de nature justement approcher
la police de sa population
vous savez le policier c'est aussi un
citoyen à part entière qui vit dans
cette ambiance anxiogène où anxiogène
aussi et qui voit aussi un jour sans fin
avec une pandémie qui n'en finit pas il
ya un virus qui circule encore plus fort
que qu'il ya quelques mois donc on est
revenu à une situation pratiquement
qu'on a vécu l'année dernière donc il ya
un ras-le-bol général aussi les forces
de l'ordre alors concernant les
effectifs
vous avez dit que vous n'étiez pas voilà
en nombre suffisant justement pour faire
appliquer on va dire c'est que ces
mesures qui sont contraignants pour pour
tout le monde
est-ce que vous en avez fait part
justement au ministre de l'intérieur d'
augmenter ses effectifs sur le terrain
vous savez le problème c'est que nous
avons des effectifs dans les
commissariats de police
mais nous avons aussi beaucoup de
missions à effectuer des missions de
police entre les centaines d'appels
police secours auxquels nous devons
faire face la lutte contre la
délinquance le trafic de stupéfiants le
terrorisme qui est toujours d'actualité
voilà on nous rajoute en plus c'est ses
interventions là pour les contrôles qui
sont chronophages et pendant qu'on fera
fc intervention là et bien on ne pourra
pas faire notre métier à savoir lutter
contre la délinquance
voilà c'est principe des vases
communicants faudra pas s'étonner donc
que les statistiques de la délinquance
peuvent remonter
merci beaucoup dans la presse avoir oui
merci beaucoup recours qu'autant
contento d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat sgp police à
paris